inflation is supposed to have peaked the
food prices are still going up and up
I've bought four mangoes they're not
very big and a pig eight pound for them
and normally you won't pay that much I
think it sounds like they've doubled in
price it's things like eggs and butter
and milk that have really gone up a lot
just the basic things buyers at Colgate
Market in Leeds are suffering and so are
sellers
customers argue with you but the thing
is
the the retailer gets the brunt of it
because we have to buy it regardless
because if you you can't have empty
shelves can you with not on it so what's
happening here well inflation in general
is beginning to slow running around 10
the food prices Rose by 20 in the year
to March it's the fastest rise in 45
years they're Rising for all types of
food but especially for dairy products
29.7 in that category cheddar cheese has
risen 42 in a year now supermarket and
dairy manufacturers say that Rising
input costs things like the cost of fuel
and wages have forced them to raise
checkout prices for things like milk
cheese and butter if you dig under the
Bonnet something else seems to be
happening new analysis by the Sky News
data team tells a bit more of a
complicated story so the input cost for
dairy manufacturers has risen but
nowhere near as much the price is
they're charging to retailers in yellow
and the price is that retailers have
charged to Consumers that's been rising
even more and look at those graphs on
the left you can see that in recent
months those prices the inputs they have
started to fall started to Flatline but
the consumer prices continue to rock it
and we can look at those input prices a
bit more detail you can see just how
much energy and Grains they were really
high but they have been coming down so
shouldn't the price of food come down
too
well the head of the national Farmers
Union warned that the pain is here to
stay I think it's about fairness in that
supply chain farmers are not going to be
able to keep producing food if they're
not getting a fair return for the costs
that they are facing into and we're
seeing effectively 50 percent cost
inflation for food producing businesses
so it's about everybody sharing that
pain she was speaking at a special
Summit for the food industry at Downing
Street government is supporting people
on the lowest income with the household
support fund payments have been going
out to people in order to help with that
particular cost of living challenge but
more broadly of course we're seeing
changes to energy cost scene then start
to come down that's critical for the
food industry as well new inflation
figures come out next week and the Sky
News data team will be looking at why
consumer prices are rising even while
the inputs are falling the government
says that food inflation isn't going
away soon bad news for all of us buying
Our Daily Bread Tom Cheshire Sky News